[Música]
você consegue citar o nome de três
arquitetos reconhecidas
internacionalmente
todos nós aqui profissionais da área ou
não a gente se lembra do oscar niemayer
rui costa ou o famoso - é mais do mesmo
a de ro
mas conta que se lembra das arquitetas
das mulheres que pensam e constroem um
espaço em que vivemos
a gente não lembra das arquitetas porque
elas não existem porque elas são
invisíveis
assim como vocês nós estudantes de
arquitetura e urbanismo
a gente foi surpreendida quando a gente
comprou essa coletânea de livros e
titulada grandes arquitetos entre os 18
nomes selecionados só tinha uma mulher e
daí a gente ficou instigado por essa
contradição foi uma contradição é
aparente
foi uma revelação que ao mesmo tempo foi
integrante intrigante mas reveladora em
um curso de graduação ou de hoje no
brasil a grande maioria dos estudantes
são mulheres
as referências são sempre masculinos e
chegadas por esse paradoxo aparentemente
inexplicável
a gente começou uma pesquisa em busca
das mulheres na arquitetura e urbanismo
quando a gente começou a fazer essa
pesquisa muitas perguntas foram surgindo
e as a cada resposta em uma nova
surpresa
a gente começou a perceber que esse
abismo ele existe não é porque as
mulheres não têm produção ou porque não
tem competência
esse abismo e existe porque as mulheres
são marginalizadas
todo esse questionamento e essa e essas
perguntas nunca feitas elas conversaram
ganhar uma força ainda maior quando a
gente começou a olhar à nossa volta
brasília símbolo da cidade planejada
pensar em cada detalhe pelos grandes
arquitetos seria nossa cidade uma
concretização dessa arquitetura feita
por hora
homens e para homens pois é
a gente é só começar a olhar à nossa
volta ea gente vê como que esse fazer
que te tônico pensado em mente derrotas
masculinas
ele acaba formando uma cidade que ela
exclui e coloca em perigo as suas
mulheres olhando pra brasília a gente
tem o exemplo das empenas cegas por
exemplo que são essas
essas paredes sem nenhuma abertura que a
gente vê na maioria dos prédios da
capital
essas empenas cegas elas foram pensadas
pelos arquitetos como grande expressivo
é detalhe arquitetônico que eles não
pensaram é que essas paredes cegas elas
formam longos caminhos escondidos que
não protegem quem está passando do olhar
protetor que poderia ser oferecido pelos
moradores deste prédio porque não
lembrar das longas distâncias e da
setorização que são um marco da cidade
também e que acabam impondo a nós
mulheres principalmente várias
dificuldades e um medo muito grande
quando a gente tem que atravessar
sozinho longos caminhos desertos pra
fazer nossas atividades diárias
alguns exemplos da história mundial eles
nos ajudarão a entender melhor e também
a explicar por que que a mulher foi
colocada assim ao longo da história da
arquitetura
um desses exemplos essa mulher é que a
sofia rei bennett
ela foi a primeira mulher a ser aceita
no curso de arquitetura não é mais
chique é mais uma faculdade bem famosa
dos estados unidos em 1891 ela ganhou um
concurso de projeto para fazer o para
fazer o projeto do edifício da mulher na
exposição colombiana que tem chicago
naquele ano embora não tenha ganhado o
projeto a construção deste edifício foi
constantemente marcada tão embate por
parte do comitê de construção que era
formado claro só por homens contra a
arquiteta
muitos consideram que esse embate e voz
oficial sanatório ainda antes da
conclusão do edifício e ela foi impedida
de ver a inauguração do projeto
a sofia ela ganhou nessa época
cerca de mil dólares para a realização
desse projeto
enquanto seus colegas homens recebiam
cerca de 10 mil para fazer um projeto do
mesmo tamanho
em outros casos a gente foi vendo como
que algumas dessas mulheres tiveram suas
produções invisibilizados ou atribuídas
exclusivamente aos seus sócios e maridos
algumas delas precisavam até mesmo do
apoio desses pra ter suas obras
legitimados aquela máxima tão comum e
não naturalizado as nossas salas mas tão
machista por trás de todo homem há
sempre uma grande mulher
o caso mais flagrante nesse é a gente
pode ver pelo prémio pritker que é o
principal prêmio da arquitetura mundial
quase 40 anos de existência este prémio
só premiou duas mulheres e uma delas foi
em conjunto com o marido
nesse desenho com o caso mais flagrante
é o da dani scott brown adenízia ao
arquiteto com formação na inglaterra e
nos estados unidos na década de 60 e
ontem uma longa produção arquitetônica
ao lado do marido o mundialmente
conhecido robert venture 91 o robert
ventura foi premiado com o prémio
pritker ignorando toda a produção ea
colaboração da avenida
hoje existe uma petição com um baixo
assinado para que a eni seja
retroativamente o laureado com o prémio
essa petição já ultrapassa a cerca de 12
mil assinaturas e ela conta com a
assinatura do marido e também da rádio
que foi a única mulher a ganhar sozinho
o prêmio é toda a gente nem precisa ou
então longe para ver esses exemplos
basta olhar à nossa volta quantas e
quantas mulheres foram apagadas pelos
seus maridos na construção de brasília
a nossa cidade é atendida histórica com
as mulheres principalmente com essas que
participaram da fase inicial de
construção da cidade
um exemplo é a mercedes parada ela fez o
mapa das desapropriações das terras na
capital embora não ficasse de noite
trabalhando nisso fazendo as medições e
os desenhos embaixo das árvores
histórias do cerrado
tava todo crente do reconhecimento por
este trabalho era o seu marido o debate
esse debate sobre tudo isso que eu tenho
falado pra vocês
e essa questão da representatividade ela
tem que se expandir
ela tem que ter até atingir não só a
formação mas também a nossa produção ao
longo desse tempo que a gente tem
trabalhado com o coletivo a gente foi
percebendo como isso pode ser expandido
são professores que começam a incluir
arquitetas e urbanistas as referências
das suas disciplinas coletivos
feministas que vão sendo formados na
faculdade de arquitetura e urbanismo em
todo o país
intervenções na cidade que pensam essa
cidade como lugar de acolhimento e não
de repressão da mulher foi um
questionamento inicialmente pequeno
restrito mas que foi intensificado pela
vivência nessa brasília dos homens e com
o tempo que a gente percebeu e que estão
questionamento que atinge todas as áreas
profissionais
mais do que isso é como uma força que se
une para que a gente forme é uma força
que vai buscar um novo caminho nessa
direção que a gente deseja as nossas
cidades elas são formadas por um cenário
múltiplo e agente enquanto arquitetos e
urbanistas e não só nós mas todos os
profissionais que trabalham no
planejamento da sociedade eles têm que
levar isso em consideração na hora de
fazer as nossas cidades se uma mulher se
sente segura no espaço e só espaço
seguro para todos
agora eu tenho certeza que vocês
conseguem me dizer o nome de três
arquitetos famosas da rádio além do bar
de dani scott brown é a sofia que eu
citei aqui agora mas se eles conseguem
me dizer o nome de três reitores de
universidade
três líderes políticas atuais
as estilistas três mulheres em cargos de
comando na sua área
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]